Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I made a little oopsie with Tomodachi Life, because I forgot
to save my island, and instead of, like, I just let it run.
So, for those who don't know, how I play Tomodachi Island is
that, or how I play Switch, or Tomodachi Life, sorry, how I
play Tomodachi Life and how I play Switch Games is that
after I'm done with it, I just closed.
OBS because I play via my OBS screen.
I have no other monitors plugged into my Switch.
Only my OBS, only my screen capture, my game capture card.
So when I booted, when I booted my Switch, I was like, oh,
I'm still in the game.
Oh, okay.
All right.
And I went in, it's like, a moment of your time, Duchess.
I was like, oh, oh yeah, my game's still running.
I forgot about that So my island was never saved so I was
just like oh, okay at least good thing good thing I didn't
close the game So my switch has been running for the last
two days.
It's a little a little oopsie just a little oopsie Anyway,
before we begin I want to do some life updates or social
media updates.
Did you guys know that I the the monks uh indicted uh a
robot into their into their monastery did you guys hear
about that overwatch is real now did you guys hear about
that overwatch is real i love the quote retweets they're
like don't tell don't tell them to go to king's room i love
i love the quote retweets Ro!
And it was like, Ride Hard is now, there's right now Gen Z!
He's 10 years old right now!
It's all coming together!
It's all coming together right now!
But yes, the first ever robotic monk has pledged itself to
Buddhism in South Korea.
So Gabi, the 4-foot-2 machine, wore traditional monk attire,
and clapped his hands together in prayer and bowed
respectfully there's like a video of this let me say i could
find it i need to find the video of this robot monk i was
like holy shit it's real it's all coming together overwatch
was just predicting the future but here you go here's here's
the video of the robot monk i'll even give you guys a little
picture of it too here he is i can't believe he's real i
can't believe it zanyada's father I was like did he even
have a choice or was he programmed to be a monk did he I was
like how did he choose to be a monk he made his debut today
did he just program that into him that means rematra's it's
okay we'll be dead okay you guys will be dead by that I'll
be there I'm for I'm here forever uh
Okay, let me give you guys the picture.
I thought I was a good life up there.
Here you go.
Here is Zenyada's great-great-grandfather.
Okay, sure.
Yeah, Joki is eternal, so don't worry.
I'll let you guys know what's going on up there when you're
up there.
What is his purpose?
His purpose is to pray.
That is his purpose.
and and to avoid king's road make sure he never goes to
king's road oh yeah sorry down there uh yeah uh what else
what else oh yeah uh little fun fact today i uh well not
today i think like two days ago i realized i've been
brushing my teeth wrong so um after x amount of years so i
don't know you guys recently saw the study about brushing
teeth but apparently you're not supposed to rinse your mouth
with water after you brush your teeth so um oops because
apparently it actually makes your it makes your teeth worse
because you're rinsing the the paste out so you're like
getting rid of it too fast because you're supposed to let it
soak onto your teeth so uh yeah i've been doing that my
whole life anyway so but then i was like What if I
accidentally swallowed a toothpaste?
So then I Googled that Because like, you know, you're
supposed to like just Spit it out, like spit out the
Remaining paste in your mouth Instead of just like getting
Instead of getting water, like you know I usually have a cup
of water and I just Rinse, I just like And I rinse it out
But you're supposed to You're supposed to Let it, you just
spit out the Excess and then just let it I guess sit on
your, on your teeth Let it, I don't know, what's the word?
Marinate your teeth so that it won't, it won't decay or some
shit.
So you can like, you can let it strengthen the core of your
enamel or some shit.
Source Twitter.
That's where I get all of my source now.
It's always Twitter.
If I do fun fact, it's Twitter.
But yeah, anyway.
But then I got worried because I tried that today and I was
like, wait, I'm swallowing my teeth.
toothpaste because I can't, I don't spit out all of, I don't
spit all of it out.
And so I was like Googling it, is it okay that I swallowed
toothpaste?
And then they're like, it's not great.
It's pretty bad.
But as long as it's like a little bit, then it's fine.
And I was just like, oh, okay.
Well, I hope it's not too bad.
I hope it,
what it, all right, let's, okay, let me Google this rinse my
mouth with water i didn't see if it was a peer-reviewed
source you should not rinse your water see oh there you go
you should not rinse your mouth with water immediately after
brushing but you should rinse with water after meals spit
out excess toothpaste but avoid rinsing to allow the
fluoride to strengthen your teeth there we go are you
looking at um Denting deep tooth decay to rinse or not to
rinse.
By rinsing with water, you're limiting fluoride's active
time in your mouth to the amount of time you've been
brushing.
There we go.
The internet.
Yeah.
See, there we go.
So you're supposed to not rinse it.
You're just supposed to let the fluoride sit on your enamel
just to strengthen it for a while.
It's too late for me.
didn't say no i think it was super chat thinking thank you
you didn't know that i took you could have it kisses back um
um but yeah like you know growing up i always use water to
uh i always use water to rinse it my my you know because i
fucking hate the toothpaste uh but you're supposed to like
brush then spit and then like let it so that it can like sit
on your tooth teeth a little Yeah, so it can absorb the
fluoride so your tooth don't decay as fast.
But yeah, a little fun fact.
I hate that feeling, though.
I've been trying to do it the last two days, and I'm not
used to it.
Also, another fun fact to everybody at university or high
school.
Canvas got hacked.
Congratulations.
Most likely your finals will be pushed back.
Bad news.
Now they have all your information.
But don't they already have all your information anyway?
like oh wow uh but anyway for those who don't know basically
uh a lot of schools university and uh high school use this i
you know i this is like post covid like this is like covid
shit so luckily i i was not i get luckily i never had to
really do online shit for my classes so um and i always
hated the online stuff but anyways basically like an on like
you know place where like they upload their coursework or
like test or study material and stuff like that and so a lot
of schools use it and it's finals week apparently it's
finals week right now and then i swear to you like it uh i
had like 10 assignments due today i was putting off for like
two weeks thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um and apparently it got hacked today and the hackers are
blackmailing or extort uh or blackmailing right now the
company um and i don't i honestly assume i honestly think
it's a student a group of students that are that were like i
don't want to do this exam or i don't want to do these
assignments during finals so let's let's hack into canvas
and then pretend we're a group of hackers trying to extort
for money like because what a coincidence that is during
finals week too you know what what a fucking coincidence
that they decide a target during finals week because they
could have used chosen any other day
music thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm a
canvas administrator it's been great.
Like, or it could be very smart.
It could be very smart because they know that the website is
going to be, the database is going to be used a lot during
finals week.
So they have to, they're like, oh shit, we have to fix this
issue because everyone needs this right now or students
won't be graduating.
It could be one or the other.
It could be both.
It could be a group of students who at first did it just to
be like, we got to, oh my gosh, cat finishes this, Simon in
time.
Oh, wait, I could also get a lot of money.
You know, two birds with one stone type deal.
They're like, I can also blackmail and extort international
company as well as not finishing my finals project.
Yeah, they're like, oh, and I can get money out of this as
well.
And go to, only if you get caught.
Only if you get caught.
I'm pretty sure they're, If they're able to hack a
multinational,
international website and breach security, I'm pretty sure
they're under 800 VPNs right now.
Anyway, let's play Tomodachi Live.
What's going on there?
Who's dying over there on the beach?
The new fountain has a money icon over it.
Let's check it out.
Wait, is she okay?
Doki, are you okay?
Where did you help Doki?
They're like, no, wishing them at Fountain.
We can help Doki later.
Anyway.
And that's your schedule.
Oh!
Donations!
Cha-ching!
Oh, I love...
Oh, my gosh.
We get to go donation diving in the Fountain.
Anyway.
And that's your Doki News Update.
On Channel 9.
I'm so much money right now.
Alright, now let's go.
Let's go help, Doki.
It looks like one or more of your residents chipped in to
donate money.
You can spend it however you like.
Just a hundred.
I bet the happier your resident arts and the more developed
your island is, the more generous they'll be with their
donations.
You'll find a new donation waiting for you once a day.
So make sure to stop by so you don't miss out.
Diving for super chats.
Hey, Doki.
Are you okay?
I'll bring someone over.
What do I bring?
Uh...
Where is...
Oh, there you are.
Let's bring Doki.
Doki, stop dancing.
You gotta help Doki.
Is this so kind of it?
Let's see here.
She needs life alert.
She does.
But she just wants to dance.
No, that's needed.
Oh, your altar friends now.
Yay!
all right let's check up on oh they're having a chat oh i
wonder what they're talking about i guess we'll never find
out oh i could add a me or oh wait there's new news joki
news network quick turn on a channel doesn't matter what
hello and welcome to the evening edition of me news after
years of trial and error researchers have finally created
the unthinkable a pop album but blue this breakthrough in
blueification was reached oh my god whatever pop album was
blue started making blue items as a part-time hobby when
asked for a quote crew from despicable me movie said the
future is blue and it starts with a pop album it remains
unclear whether this was a threat we asked residents for
their Yeah.
We heard about this all the time back when I was a kid.
Thank you for watching.
Um, this is pretty interesting.
What do you mean, Doki?
All right.
Thank you for watching Channel 9.
All right, Doki.
Oh, Dokafield.
Hey, Doki.
What's up?
Hey, there.
I've been thinking.
lately that dokey and i could get to know which dokey oh
sexy dokey oh my god dokey field wants to interact with sexy
dokey well maybe there is something there
oh he she vibes with her
see i told you she's so popular sexy dokey is so popular
with on the island All right, sexy Doki, what do you want?
Your standards are too low, Doki feel.
All right, what about you, sexy Doki?
I want to be friends with Doki.
Which one?
Okay, oh, that Doki.
Okay, we should talk about being so sexy.
What did you have in mind?
Let's see.
What can Doki talk about with Doki?
Wait, what is the last one?
And it starts with an A.
I don't know what that is.
Oh, an activity.
Oh, my gosh.
What should we talk about?
Uh...
An activity.
Paying our taxes.
Okay.
not wait wait not committing committing
is that how you spell committing tax fraud not committing
tax fraud guys oh is it too uh Not committing tax fraud Let
me fix it Not committing Tax fraud I wish there was like
Spell checker Autocorrect on the switch Alright, not
committing tax fraud Guys Got it I'll go talk to her about
not committing tax fraud They're always watching guys
They're always watching Good evening, Doki.
Hey, Doki.
Do you feel like talking about?
Not committing tax fraud.
Okay, but check this out.
Visualize not committing tax fraud.
Who do you want to join?
Do you visualize it?
I know it's so hard.
It's so hard to do.
I pick you.
Oh, me?
I know.
I'm so good at not committing tax fraud.
I'm gonna pencil you in for not committing tax fraud ASAP.
I'm visualizing it.
Oh my god, I'm thinking about it.
I'm thinking about keeping all my receipts.
I'm thinking about talking to my tax guy, my accountant, and
then making sure I pay everything on time.
Oh, I'm thinking it's so hard right now.
That's so true.
Look at that.
Now we are bonded by not committing tax fraud.
together nice i knew not committing text fraud would bring
doki and me together makes sense doki and i have the same
taste in hobbies so no one's waiting thank you with a super
chat thank you thank you i'm visualizing properly detailing
my deductions and trying trying to see which one is a
business expense and which one is a uh personal expense i'm
visualizing it i'm visualizing it right now i i love giving
my money to the the government and giving them 30 to 40
percent of my earnings and that's why I love not committing
tax fraud.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why does that look like a blow up tall?
Quite didn't think of the super chat.
Thank you.
But enough, I just filed my tax return after I almost got
scammed on tax day.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
right now?
Don't worry.
I'm spreading the good word on not committing tax fraud.
You know, I am a well-adjusted citizen in the great country
of Canada.
I am a law-abiding citizen.
No Canada.
Welcome.
I'm spreading the good word.
All right.
Let's see what we have here.
Natulas, gelatin snacks, spinach, carrot cake.
Oh, if we buy spinach, we're gonna be so buff, just like my
hero, Papa.
You hear that, cops?
She pays her taxes.
Oh my god, wait, track suit.
Let's see.
We have to buy this.
The ragged dress.
There's a shrimp tail.
Oh, wait.
there's a backpack oh my god okay but then you can't really
see anything a marathon outfit these are some good elf i'm
just gonna buy them in advance just in case i need them
sending money to make it harder to not commit tax fraud oh
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you let's see
we'll buy we're just gonna buy all of these like in advance
oh casual overall okay we're gonna Kevin, for now.
I have a lot of money so I can spend this.
All right, we'll buy...
Do we have a tracksuit of?
I'm going to buy...
I don't remember if we bought tracksuit of them.
I'm going to buy this.
They're all blurring together.
I'm going to buy this just in case.
Because I don't remember what I bought and what I haven't
bought.
All right, I think that's good.
One of our shirts, if they...
Oh, there is.
Okay.
I don't think...
Yeah, none of them...
these.
We need it right now.
None of these work for me right now.
Oh?
What are you dreaming about, Kevin?
Let's watch his movie.
Oh, he wants to fly.
He's doing it, Kevin!
Just minion stuff.
You Got this, Kevin.
Just keep on trying.
It'll eventually work.
You're in a dream.
Speaking about Canada, get excited that Alberta is trying
for the 100th time to secede from Canada.
Thank you for the super chat, bro.
Okay, thank you.
If Quebec can't do it, I'm sorry, Alberta.
I think Quebec is first, though.
If anyone, like if any territory is trying to secede from
Canada, I think Quebec should be first though.
I, they've been trying for years.
Mayhaps decades.
It just wouldn't be fair at this point.
All right, let's give him the overalls.
Where the fuck did I buy it?
Oh, there it is.
Casual.
If Alberta can do it before Quebec, I will be very
impressed.
I will be very surprised.
All right, nice.
What do you think about it?
I'm not the biggest fan of spring.
All right.
We're getting closer.
Is she still saying I love Doki?
Oh, the sea.
Where are the others?
Uh...
Oh, yeah, wait.
Doki, talk to Doki.
Hey!
I love to see!
Yeah, they got tips!
They called shotgun!
I wanna try not to miss it!
What?
Wait, what did she say?
Wait, it's so fast.
It's so slow.
Wait, what about committing tax fraud?
What about it, Toki?
I scrolled out too fast.
I didn't see.
I scrolled too fast.
I didn't know what she said about tax fraud.
Oh.
I took me.
Oh, they're best friends and ultra friends.
Oh, they all just want to talk.
Come on, guys, do something.
Oh, oh, dokefield.
Of course.
Dokefield.
You're lazy about.
All right, dokefield.
Why don't you talk to...
Whoa.
They're here to discuss finding the truth.
The truth to what?
Oh, that's...
Let's...
Let's embarrass Doki real quick.
Let's get it all nervous and shy.
Oh, Doki is staring at Doki.
Guys, talk to each other.
Oh, my God.
This is my escapism.
Stop being like Doki.
And interact with each other.
Oh, my God.
Doki's.
Oh, hey, Guru.
Hmm.
Sure.
Let's play.
What's missing from this picture?
I made them too accurate.
What?
Oh, kimchi.
The bite of 67?
Is that?
Where is the bite?
Hmm.
So what's missing from here?
Three, two.
Uh, tomato juice.
What's missing is?
Oh, you're right.
Try the restaurant.
And finally, the last picture.
So what's missing from here?
Three, two, one.
Time's off.
What?
Okay, I was not prepared for that's bullshit.
They're like, here are twofold pictures.
Well, anyway, what happened 1935 on Thursday?
Like, this is the color.
What object is the color blue?
What object is a color green?
What happened 1935 on Tuesday 5 p.m?
My goat watch.
How the fuck was I supposed to know that?
What happened on 1935 on Thursday, Doki?
I don't know.
That's why I asked you.
Good evening.
Yep.
All right.
Now you two can come over.
Hang out with all of them.
Talk to them!
Interact with them, Doki!
Oh, you don't want to talk to Doki, but you want to talk to
Kevin.
Oh, my...
Oh, it's because they're just acquaintances.
Oh, my God.
Cruz.
Doki's poop.
for Groo!
It's a monoshoot!
Oh, it's beautiful.
That's right.
To the left now.
This way.
Look at me.
Oh, fabulous, Doki.
Fabulous!
I have a little photo shoot there.
For only Doki's.
She's so popular.
And you guys didn't want Doki to join the island you know
what i think we need a new resident on the island i think
it's time all right let's see from scratch all right let's
see how to make this this might be hard
uh let me see how i can so let's see if i can make this real
quick though
shit wait that's so good i'm trying to grab a reference so I
can make this accurately.
Oh,
wait.
There it is.
Is it this?
Can I do it this?
Oh, this is going to be hard.
Okay, I think I can do it.
I think I can do it.
I need to get the...
though.
Let me grab the dokey.
The dokeypedia.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I think it's possible.
It needs to be this.
It is a fan favorite.
I see you.
I see everyone.
Baking for this particular Doki for so long.
And the eyes are...
Okay, they have you water, though.
Like that.
Alright, and then the nose.
It's time for the fan favorite to join.
To join Doki Island.
Doki Island.
There's no is this
No, I don't think the nose can work as a beak, but it can be
obviously the mouth and then
Okay, we have to do the makeup now it all relies on the
makeup
It all relies on the makeup
Okay, there you go
Then color range and we gotta make it a bit darker here
Forget tax fraud.
Joke is clearly into human cloning.
Make yourself an army of the Blue Mountain group.
Thank you for the super chat.
Acer.
Thank you.
And now I gotta make sure if I can do this.
Oh, I can make it.
Wait.
Because it's like an upside down square.
Watch this, guys.
Okay.
okay I don't know what okay wait because it's like half a
square wait no it's like a triangle what am I saying I guess
I might not know my shapes okay
yeah you like this and then
oh okay then we fill this up and then oh
my god it's beautiful I'm so good at this okay
maybe not like that yeah you see that vision you see the
vision?
All these Doki has led to this Doki.
Okay, maybe I got I'm just gonna I'm just gonna copy and
paste this part.
Maybe that might be easier.
And then
wait, where is this?
Oh, there it is.
How do I flip?
Oh, this way.
boom okay I think that's good and then I think that's good I
think it's complete I don't think there's anything else I
have to add it is a little weird with no hat honestly it's a
little weird that he's just bald like that but we'll take
what we can get here.
Let me sharpen this up a little bit, though.
I don't like how.
He just needs a hat.
Guys.
She just needs a hat, and it'll look not as weird.
It's just a lack of hat, okay?
The moment she has a hat, everything will look okay.
Everything will look right.
Oh, maybe bigger eyes, honestly.
There we go.
She's, like, tiny.
Doki.
My name is Doki.
Uh, female.
69.
It just looks off because she doesn't have a hat, okay?
She's just hatless Okay, I need to be like
I need to like try to figure
I'm trying to figure out the pitch
Okay, that's good
There you go I didn't ask good That's a good that's a good
right there.
Alright, Doki.
No.
Okay, Doki's quick.
Doki is a bird, so Doki doesn't care.
Doki is also...
Alright.
Doki's like...
She's a chill bird.
I'll say.
She's pretty quirky for a bird, I'll say.
She's a talking bird, so...
I'd say that's pretty quirky.
Okay.
Anything can happen.
She don't think.
That is true.
You're right.
She don't think at all.
There's nothing inside that little brain of hers.
She's just a bird.
Follows their instincts.
Radiant always on for him.
Their effortless style is my ball.
Easily adapts to a new situation.
Oh, she still ages.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, she's old.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, I forgot!
She's gonna age!
I'll put her next to here.
Okay, let's fix that.
Don't worry, Kroki.
We found...
We found the fountain of youth.
Kroki, you'll never die.
You'll never grow old.
But...
Don't age.
Alright, don't worry.
We fixed it.
Don't worry.
We fixed you, Kroki.
We found the source of eternal life.
Jokies are eternal.
Oh?
What's going on?
Oh!
Our island's bigger now!
Let's go!
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
We're developing the sea around, not related to other
islands, has progressed nicely, making it possible to expand
the island.
The excited resident is quoted as saying, I hope we can keep
growing the island.
We expanded the parking lot, guys.
The whole world is the island.
I was like wondering, it's like, oh my god, how am I going
to fit all these people on my island?
All right, let's grab a hat for Kroki.
Uh, oh, that's not a hat.
That's not a hat.
Let's grab a hat.
Thank you for the super chat, Papa.
Thank you.
All right.
We'll give you a normal hat for now.
Because I don't have any other hats right now.
So, I mean...
Oh, do I not have any other blue hats?
Was that the only...
Oh, I do.
Okay.
We'll grab you a hat.
Just because, like, that's the only thing I have.
Oh, they're all talking in the restaurant.
Um...
All right.
All right, Kroki.
I can give you a hat.
There's just something a little off, and I don't like it.
I don't like that you're bald, so we gotta cover that spot
up.
There we go.
Yay!
Oh, I could draw hats.
You're right.
I could make it the color.
The actual color.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
You should have food, too.
Do I have enough?
Wait, I forgot to buy.
Since you're a dokey, I don't know.
We have to get you... Wait, is she okay?
Uh, we'll get to her later.
This is more important.
Welcome.
Okay, where is it?
Alright.
Thank you very much.
We gotta make sure to feed Gorky.
As an honor, as a dokey, she needs to go through the
initiation.
Oh, we're gonna try bowling?
Let's do bowling!
Alright, bowling first.
Ha!
Oh my god, we have enough villages for bowling, guys!
Yay!
Excuse me, what the fuck?
I gotta split?
If I hit here, it's gonna, like, hit Kevin.
No!
It didn't hit Kevin!
Okay, I fucked up.
I should have just went in the middle.
Oh my god.
We got spare.
Too bad.
In my head, I was thinking...
that Doki would hit Kevin.
I don't think I've won a single game yet.
They're just so good!
They're outsmarting me!
All these Doki's they're all outsmarting me!
They just know how I think.
It's not fair.
Alright.
I got the bite of 67.
Did you like it?
Oh, she liked it yeah more wishes oh my god really how far
out close are you to it all right who should doki meet uh oh
doki's fine oh wait let's let doki meet the other doki's
meet the gang doki and kevin hey nice to meet you i'm doki
nice to meet you doki On Doki.
Yay!
Oh, nice.
Good job, Doki.
Make some friends.
You got this.
Yay!
Doki, Doki, Doki, and Kevin.
Thank you.
Doki, I am really getting it all.
You're welcome, Doki.
Oh, my God.
I'm so proud of you, Doki.
All right, Doki.
Meet the other Doki.
Oh my god, we're all dokees.
If you're dokees and I'm dokees, then who's not dokees?
How much she's into not getting...
Oh, me too, dokees.
Me too.
I'm glad we're all on the same page about not committing a
federal crime.
All right, there you go.
Let's go to the wishing well.
All right, let's go wish.
time wish wish oh i can still have uh oh yeah i won't buy oh
island landscaping i have an idea or island object actually
yes i'd like to create an island object please
oh i'll go to phase clan's house joki's thinking about
something huh good evening all right dokey what is it be
friends with dokey oh yeah sure everybody wants to be
friends with dokey oh my god dokey is so popular oh others
let's see what did you have in mind i think okay
lasagna I mean, of course.
Got it.
I'll go talk to her about a lasagna.
I mean, that's the way to her heart.
Good evening, Doki.
Do you feel like talking about...
A lasagna?
Sure.
But let me ask you this.
Yeah, what is it?
Someone offers you a large lasagna or a small lasagna.
Which one are you going with?
I know not everyone would agree, but I'm going with a small
lasagna.
Why would you pick a small lasagna?
What?
Toki!
Oh, if you choose a small lasagna, you can have multiple
lasagnas.
Think about it, guys.
Think about it.
When you order a big lasagna, you can order one big lasagna.
small lasagna's.
You can order five lasagna's and then put the other four in
the fridge later.
Is that right?
Doki, that's what you mean, Doki Field, right?
That's what you're gonna order.
Doki, multiple large.
This is breaking the law.
They're stackable, exactly.
You can stack small lasagna.
I friended up with Doki by talking about a small lasagna.
my face.
Isn't that Doki the best conversationalist around?
Yeah micro dosing lasagna.
Think about it chat.
You can micro dose lasagna.
And also small lasagna.
You can guarantee that the lasagna is baked evenly on all
sides.
We just received some wonderful news.
Oh we got not committing tax fraud, Doki bird being so sexy
and gambling.
He is done not related to other islands.
Residents can't hide their joy.
Calling in with comments like, We never have to worry about
running out of things to talk about with all these new
things to say.
Oh my god, all these wonderful words.
Yay!
I got a trophy.
I got an award.
EWW EW will be presented with a run speech bubble thank you
everybody I tried my best I'm a good god exactly you get too
big of a lasagna doesn't cook in the middle right exactly
see they know what they're talking about we should never
never doubt Dokefield WWE WWE WWE you don't want to see a
complete list of your island lingo please press x and select
island info from there you can view and adjust how lingo is
read or even delete lingo that you don't want to hear
anymore so you made them say something really fucking stupid
he could start deleting it from their vocab oh oh yeah this
is what i want to make new creation please objects
magic cubes and there's so many different shapes your
creation can take think outside boss and you make your
island truly unique i have an idea already of what i want to
make it'll be a cube shape wait i can make a house oh i can
make somebody's house okay no i won't make a box
Wait, is it a full box?
Oh, it's a full box.
Wait, what is the cylinder?
Oh my god, I can make a pancake.
Okay.
I guess I have to go...
Wait, what does the dome look like?
Oh, that's cool.
I like that.
Oh my god, this is actually, like, playing with textures and
shit.
Okay, well, I have an idea.
adjust it.
Oh, I need that.
Yeah.
Wait, I had an idea in my head.
Give me a sec.
Oh, my God.
The idea.
Wait, wait.
Not for this one.
But there was another idea I wanted to do.
So, it, like, disappeared from my head.
I was like, oh, my God.
That's brilliant.
Doki.
Oh, my God.
I can't wait to do that.
Next stat.
And then now it's gone.
It's gone now.
Oh, my God.
It was so... It was so funny, too.
It was so funny.
Not for this.
This one already know what I'm doing.
but there was this other idea that I wanted to do, and it
was so funny.
No!
I'll never remember.
It's gone forever.
I should have wrote it down.
Anyway, I know what I'm doing for this.
I was just sad.
I forgot.
Why didn't I write it down?
Okay, wait.
Let me see if I can remember it.
I'm going to see if I can remember it, guys.
It was so funny.
Oh my god, I should do that.
No!
What was it?
Oh my god.
It's God.
It's God forever.
It's okay, we still have this though.
Oh wait, it's in the same color.
I had to redo the color.
I told you she's God.
I told you.
She's God.
She's never coming back.
Chris.
Okay, and then we got to move this up.
Okay, and then I can put...
And then...
20...
6...
Where's the dash?
2...
20...
6.
Oh, fuck, it's the wrong color!
Not again!
Gotta rewrite this.
20, 20, 6, 2, 20, 20, 6.
Rest in peace.
Alright, and then...
Wait, can I draw from here?
Oh, no, I can't.
Goodbye.
She's never coming to Doki Island.
This is so sad.
Can we get some more ships?
The chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Hey guys.
Thank you.
Thank you for the five gift of the shows.
Boom.
There's grass.
This looks like grass, right?
There you go.
And then there's grass there.
Mike, thank you for the thank you for the five, uh, one gift
and chips, thank you, thank you.
Oh, seven.
Gone, gone, not soon enough.
Yeah.
There you go, and then there's grass.
Dead grave.
Oh.
Oh, we just call it grave.
Oh, shit, okay.
Grave.
but
we're thank you for the 10 gift of ships thank you thank you
there you go nice uh finish we can't make it plasticky the
plastic gravestone she couldn't afford she was broke tank
dokey was broke stinky not unmute okay it's stinky it's a
rod and corpse appearance
Yeah.
Cold.
Her spirit still haunts the grave.
Stone was too expensive, guys.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It could be, like, giant.
I could actually make it skinnier.
Yeah, that makes sense.
There you go.
AKC, thank you for the bomb.
Give the ships they can thank you.
all right let's buy this gravestone welcome we monetized her
death
all right and then all right
let's see island builder
build oh there it is there's the grave let's put it next to
the vending machine actually where do we put it we put in a
fountain oh i can't put it in front of the fountain We can
put it next to Doki's house.
Or we put it...
Oh yeah, let's put it next to the vending machine.
Never forget.
Is that going to thank you for 10 gift dishes?
Thank you.
Never forget.
Take Doki.
Is there a never forget memorial?
There's been horrifying rumors about Fortnite.
What's up with Crew?
Crew, don't we?
being so sexy across what's wrong Groo no
there's so many donkeys on this island you chose Kevin
looking at Kevin from It's your employee!
Did you have to go to HR for this?
The crew, he's your minion!
Do we let him...
Do we tell him he's...
The crew fell in love with the only guy on the island.
It was all women and he fell in love.
Groot, you know an office romance never works out, Groot.
You know it.
It only makes things so messy.
The forbidden fruit.
It's true.
It's Groot love.
Spare Kevin from the donkey.
I just...
All right.
It must be love.
It's like this can't be anything but love.
I'm going to take a deep breath and ask Kevin for me.
Now?
Right now.
You just fell in love.
What can I see you're doing?
Is he?
Okay, not yet.
Not yet.
Okay.
Go for it, Groot.
Urban rival.
Rival Rival's Legends.
Alright, we got another Wish.
He's not getting any younger, Doki.
There's still can't get...
Oh, I can't see saw.
I think I should get a see saw.
Can I travel anywhere yet?
Oh, I can't go to Hawaii yet.
Grab a see saw.
Fuck it.
Let's add that in here.
Can't believe it, girl.
employee he works under you what's that word call when
there's like a there's like a fucking dynamic there already
what's that word call when you're like the boss hooks up
with like one of their employees there's a power dynamic
here there's a power imbalance HR is not gonna like this
crew like all
right let's grab it's called getting a promotion let's grab
a yellow seesaw uh and i want to build the crew is hr though
i already had a seesaw i didn't even know that oh wait i
could wait what
oh my god i could put in the fountain oh i can't never mind
i thought i could it looked like i could for a sec they're
patting towards the yowie fantasy of the donkeys as the only
two males it just had to be oh we'll put a seesaw next to
the gravestone donky would i've wanted this
would have wanted this.
Gru and Kevador is literally like their only entertainment.
They're saying no one really knows.
No one really knows.
Some say the Duchess could also be a fellow Doki, but we'll
never know.
Oh, oh, they're all heading into the restaurant.
Oh, they're both, oh, Doki and Doki are eating together.
Oh,
Doki all right what else is going on oh dokey wants to talk
all right dokey oh my god dokey's playing with amagas I've
got some time to spare do you want to play no repeats with
me I share no
repeat food I got this chocolate toast hard-boiled egg
Educational.
Oh shit.
I forgot the first rule.
I forgot the theme was food.
I was like, educational game.
I- That's sad.
Food can be educational.
If we make- If we play a game based off of food, it could be
educational.
All right, let's get it.
Let's get...
Oh, wait.
I'm going to all hang out.
Oh, what are they talking about?
Say, Doki, you know a lot about using a lasagna, huh?
Well, I have so many tissues, guys.
You know everything there is to know about using a lasagna.
How do you use a lasagna?
Doki, where are you doing lasagna for it?
scholar and exaggeration i assure you you know so much more
everyone calls you all lasagna you haven't heard that
nickname i suppose i have not but i must object my lasagna
knowledge fails by comparison to yours i cry just thinking
about it well that went a bit far didn't it lasagna
scholarship we're trying to make the perfect lasagna you're
still working so hard on it What do I give all my tissues
to?
Oh, look.
There's Doki playing with Amagas.
Look at him go.
You're the first of your kind I've ever seen, Amagas.
It's the first of his kind.
It's the first of his kind, guys.
It's like an endangered species.
I forgot that.
I'm gonna give Gru some of my tissues.
Oh, she's happy.
You know what will make you happier?
Some toilet paper.
Wait, when did I have a bird feather?
I don't remember getting that.
Here you go.
Oh, you don't like it?
What?
You not wipe?
What do you mean it's not a good match for you?
Do you not wipe, Gru?
Oh, he might have a bidet.
Guys, he might have a bidet.
God, I wish I had a bidet.
Why do you guys have a top?
Doki, good evening.
Kevin from the minions movie.
Good evening.
All right, how about you talk with Doki?
Or is that a bit surprising for her to have?
Yeah, but that didn't...
it.
I don't, I'm too lazy for that.
I mean, could get someone to install it for me.
The only issue is that it is a rented place, so then like I
have to, I think, I don't have to ask my landlord if I need
permission to install it by day.
Alright.
Oh, I can do something.
Oh, can I?
No, I can't.
Yeah, I still rent.
Alright.
Oh!
Gru wants to talk to me.
Hey, Gru.
And your psychotic room?
Hey, there.
And you're all white wallpaper with no doors room.
I've always admired smart people.
And if I want people to admire me, I've got to get smart
clothes.
I want some clothes that make me look smart.
You look great.
Yeah, I think you already look very smart, girl.
You're not getting new clothes, man.
This is how school this is going to get.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Oh?
What are you talking about?
They were living memories with hopes in their eyes.
It's why all the Doki's always talking about that.
They think they're leaking top secret info.
Oh, Doki does.
Oh, Doki doesn't think so.
Doki's just like, wait, Doki, stop smiling.
What's going on?
Oh, no, she's smiling again.
Why is this room just loading me?
Because he doesn't have Kevin yet.
He doesn't have Kevin in his life.
I remember now.
I remember what I wanted to...
draw.
Okay, I'm writing this down.
It came back to me.
Alright, don't worry, Doki.
I'll help you.
I'll help her myself.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh.
Whoa.
Don't worry, Doki.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Whoa.
What did she say?
Don't worry, I'm hoping.
I'm hoping.
There we go.
Yeah, I fixed her, guys.
I fixed her.
Yay!
Self-love.
My thoughts drifted to Chidoki, and I got so nervous, I
froze up.
Alright, let's see.
Oh.
Oh, okay, I think we're ready for a new resident, guys.
I think we're ready.
I know exactly what we're gonna get.
It should be like this.
I think Doki Island is ready.
Doki Island is finally ready.
It's Dragoon time.
Where's the dog eyes?
Oh, there it is.
The dragon is finally allowed on Doki Island.
The visa has been approved.
And we did learn how to draw birds.
Okay, I need to actually pull up a reference.
Yeah.
How did it look like?
How did you guys look like?
All right, let's see.
Oh, wait, I know how to do the hair.
How's that?
No, not this.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
And all I have to do is...
Okay, maybe not the mohawk.
Maybe...
I guess that or oh Oh wait wait maybe okay either this or oh
I think this I think this works This is as close as it could
get Oh they give it a super chat they can thank you I swear
to god I swear if you put me in prison today Because all
right wait give me a sec I'm gonna feed dad real quick guys
All right Do we want chonky goon or regular goon Which one?
Or Longoon?
I mean, regular Goon and Longoon look the same.
Alright, I'll do a poll.
I'll let the dragoons decide which dragoon you want on the
island.
I'm sorry, Longoon.
But like, we can't make the neck any longer.
The Doki Islands only approved one visa.
And they said, no longuans allowed.
Life is unfair.
Only one visa got approved.
I'm sorry.
It's very hard to get residencies here.
Yeah.
One of the hardest places to get residency.
To get your visa approved.
And wait.
Yes.
Oh That's fine
Yeah, unless your name is Doki They only let It's very very
hard To get residency
On Doki Island
But your Doki it's like free it's like free game They give
you a house and everything they give you a free house if
your name is Doki
all right there you are i can't wait for dragon to marry
doki the baby will be precious
oh you poor fool
there's always a catch on doki
He doesn't know there's always a catch on turkey island.
Does he know?
It's part of the visa process.
Okay.
That's good.
Oh my god, I'm getting better at this.
You can tell which Mia is like my first Mia.
Which one is, which one is like the most recent one?
Why don't Doki Island make the Ivy Triangles game?
Thank you for the super chat, Alan.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
It looks like Chonki-Goon is winning.
Nice.
All right.
Let's see.
I think it'd make it like a triangle, right?
And then I'm just gonna smooth it out.
And then I'm gonna brush.
Okay, and then...
Boop!
Yeah!
I'm not gonna shade this.
There's no need for shading.
There you go!
I think that's good!
Little not off-center, but that's okay.
You were just born a little quirky.
A little off-centered.
Guys, you're not going to be born in Omago.
But, you know.
It's a face that a mother would love.
Alright.
Junkie Goon.
I think that's good.
You're extra tight.
Oh, you're extra.
Chonky.
There's a lot of Chonky residents on this island, which I've
noticed.
We might need to go, we might have to start promoting
fitness, guys.
There's a lot of Chonky villagers.
There's a lot of short Chonky villagers here.
It's you guys.
Dragon.
It's all the lasagna.
My name is Dragoons.
I think I think actually yeah so we get all of them all
right everything and then
all right I can go lower we'll do 18 and then oh wait I got
an IDL uh wait I have an idea.
My name is Dragoon.
Get it?
Because you're a view bot.
My name is Dragoon.
It's nice to meet you.
These guys aren't real.
Get it?
My name is Dragoon.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 7th.
Real, don't...
Yeah, because you guys aren't real.
I can't...
I was doing the third...
My name is Dragoon.
I'm not...
Real?
That's right, my viewbot number 5445.
Wait, are we...
Webots?
We came sentience?
All in your mind.
What am I?
It can't be.
Today is May 7th, 2020.
We're a trick.
We're all in my head.
Maybe I am a clanky.
So everyone but me is a view body.
My name is Trincoo.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 7th, Twins.
Hello, Mr. Toon.
My name is Toon.
My name is...
It's nice to meet you.
It's always nice to meet you.
My name is Toon.
It's nice to meet you.
my name is dragoons it's nice to meet you my name is
dragoons it's nice to meet you well that sounds just like
that just sounds like like a telemarketing my name is
dragoons
my name is dragoons yeah it sounds like tts yes it sounds
like a tts i don't know they're all so good it's nice to
meet you my name is dragoons goons it's nice to meet you
what the fun
it just make you sound like corpse fried by like that one
Look at your ultra fried voice.
All right, here.
Do you want to play a game?
All right.
Wait.
Let's see.
No.
It's all free for all.
It's a free for all.
Okay, you're all in the middle.
Okay.
Everything in the middle.
Alright, I think we're good.
Aloof, logical, tenacious, cautious, speaks matter of
factly.
Yeah, you guys are mid.
Imagine if it inspired, happiest when creating something.
Finds beauty in everyone and everything.
Welcome!
Alright, let's put your house here.
We're just gonna keep expanding it from the side.
I'm not being creative right now.
Alright.
Oh.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Who's our good dragon?
You are.
Alright, don't worry.
I got you some food dragons.
Now that you live on Doki Island, you got your visa
approved.
Here's the bite of 67.
How do you feel?
Yay!
Everyone loves it.
See?
All right.
I have an idea, yeah.
Yeah.
Dang you, Dragon.
Oh, that's sweet.
Alright, Dragon.
Remember when I said there's always a catch?
Where is that, Doki?
Hey, Dragoons.
I'm Doki.
Yay!
Now you're no sexy dude.
Wait up.
Yeah, I did it.
Look at that.
You're friends now.
Guys, look at that.
These are your choices, dragoons.
What's the gathering of banana?
Yes, welcome to Tokyo Island.
Kevin is a hotter Kevin or sexy toky nice to meet you I'll
take what I Kevin Kevin now you're here for a you gotta
leave toky island can we invade ourselves Mr. Muffloff and
kids I choose Kevin I juice, Kevin?
Yeah, for sure.
Of course.
Alright.
I'm glad I have this not a lot.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But Kevin is our new Oshi.
What are they talking about?
Hey, so I don't know if you're interested, but I was
thinking do something for today oh sorry i can't no i've got
a thing what the no donkey got rejected by donkey i've
always wanted to tell you you could really walk about that
suit really that's funny because my parents raised me to
never Ever wear a latte suit?
Uh,
do you want me?
Yes or no?
And so quick?
Oh, um.
Oh.
You're okay.
The worst she can say is no, guys.
The worst she can say is no.
They don't know.
They don't know if they're friends.
They don't know if he likes it or not.
It's a mystery.
It's a mystery, guys.
Oh, well, they haven't just seen me talk.
They were recounting heroic tales from times of old.
Oh, let's have...
Let's see.
Oh!
Doki wants to play.
I mean, you're okay.
Let's play Shadow Quiz.
Oh, Shadow Quiz.
I'm good at that.
This might be the game where I finally win.
Here's your first mystery Shadow.
What do you think it is?
Amogus?
Oh, this is so easy.
A bite of 67.
I got...
I think this might be the first game I win, guys.
What the fuck is that?
I guess, like, a mysterious liquid?
There's no way it's a Panicata.
Yeah.
Oh, my God, I did it!
It's the first game.
I'll win!
Doki bird.
What do I get?
I'll get the big one.
Big one's always the best.
Ooh, music.
What the fuck was the middle?
Was that you soft?
Hey, Doki says winning.
I want something, Doki.
You know what?
I'm going to re-gift this to you.
Where is it?
Wait, where is it?
What the fuck did she give me?
Here you go, we'll get Reggae.
You gave me Reggae, I'll give it back to you.
Oh, you don't like it?
Oh, she likes it.
Yay!
Okay, wait, I have something I wanted to draw.
Uh, oh, Kevin, what do you want?
Um, let's play Pixel Quiz.
Pixel Quiz, what's that?
Here's your first pixelated item.
What do you think it is?
What the fuck?
Lemonade?
The answer is...
Oh!
Nice.
Next up, your second pixelated item.
What do you think it is?
Oh, that's pasta.
Oh, what?
I mean, there's red on it.
The answer is...
I think it's smoked salmon, right?
Yeah, it is.
And finally, the last pixelated item.
What do you think it is?
What the fuck is that?
It's just...
I mean creme brulee because it has like gold on there Oh
yeah, I know my colors.
I know my creme brulee Fucking good as shit creme brulee is
really good I'm like craving creme.
I almost ordered an ice cream cake for myself Like at late
at night.
I was like craving ice cream.
I did it.
Oh my god We're on a winning streak right now The big one.
I almost... I almost...
Oh my god, I've got a turtle.
Oh wait, I got Martian Rock.
Wait, that's even better than a turtle.
I can sell that on eBay.
I was craving ice cream cake just last night.
But I resisted.
I showed restraint, chat.
I am strong-willed.
My morning old banana clash.
Magic a pile of documents.
Oh no, it's all the tax papers that I've been filing because
I do not commit tax fraud.
Oh hey, I got a music box.
Dairy queen.
You can always get ice cream cake.
Oh, I love dairy queen with ice cream cakes.
It's like my favorite type of ice cream cake because of the
fudge at the, um, the fudge at the end.
It's so good.
The vanilla with the chocolate and the fudge.
Explain it, but Groove from Despicable Me movie is on my
mind all the time lately.
It's all in your head, mine.
That doesn't, that doesn't fit my plan.
Wait, oh wait, I could have a triangle though.
Oh my god, I could have a love triangle.
Wait, it sounds right.
Wait, no, we have to make this, this good, the drama.
I like it.
Total drama island.
Despicable Me movie in that way before.
But hearing you think it's love is making me wonder oh my
god love island is real total drama island All the islands
except for that one island that we're not related to But a
little quirt Uh
Sands cutely Sands while shaking his we didn't give heard
something already, but I don't remember.
Oh, it's walks cutely.
Yes.
Oh, we're safe for now.
Have anything else?
I'll blow bubbles.
I'll give her a bubble blower.
Oh, you give her eyes as a vocal cord.
Oh, my!
That's beautiful.
Shout out to Faded Music, guys.
For the amazing idea.
Remember.
Remember Faded Music.
We're giving us that idea.
Oh, there's Dragon.
No more play.
Keep talking to her.
Dragon's, good evening.
Feels a little full as your thing is worth and possibly make
a friend.
Yes!
It's all coming together.
It's all coming together!
But um What is Oh, is Borden wants some company?
I got you We'll grab Kevin over Stop forcing it The two
items the chef recommends are entirely different I know
which one I've got my eyes on Same here Okay, let's both
point to the one we want
What is it?
Is that Ratatouille?
Oh, that's good, because they don't have to share it.
You know, they don't fight over it.
Of course, Doki Field will choose pasta.
I had a fun time with Doki.
And if I'm being honest, it's all thanks to you.
That's just 22.
You're welcome.
I know I worked so hard to make this island possible.
Oh.
what?
Hey, Doki.
Are you okay?
She's practicing.
Really?
I have no idea you felt that way.
That's me disassociating.
So, how about we start going on my God?
She's getting ready.
She's practicing for asking her up.
Oh.
Wait, she got friend zone in her own reenactment.
That's pretty sad, Doki.
She's the Lulu right now.
Never give up, Doki.
Never give up.
Bro got friend zone by herself.
Oh?
I'll bring someone over.
Should I go get over here?
I just can't.
I'm like playing dollhouse right now.
No, stop.
Yay!
Oh my god, Dragon, you're so kind for helping Tokyo.
Oh, now you're vibing.
Now you have it.
Look at that hanging out together.
Let's grab this.
You can't afford anything yet.
Oh, she's...
She's watching her.
Oh, she's jealous.
Right now.
She's so jealous of Kevin.
Don't worry.
Doki.
go hang out with them make her even more jealous
good evening dokey oh oh my god now she's gonna she's gonna
eavesdrop from here oh look at that look at you too oh my
god you guys are hitting it off oh my god Kevin better watch
out
oh you guys are going to a restaurant together oh you're
gonna get tables again guys oh my god it's happening so
naturally it's progressing so naturally right now with no
interference oh no I see they're calling their Lord lost
fortnight V bucks I'm gonna play with Doki he needs friends
to play with
hi dokey oh that's it you guys are just gonna say hi oh i'm
gonna play with dokey yay right next to tank dokey's grave
let's go she would have wanted that oh he's so oh hey having
fun with your toilet paper grew he's having it's so
interesting i know he's like what can i do with this toilet
paper many uses for it.
Oh, the treasure shop.
Wait, can I?
Please come again.
Take-Doki will not return in Avengers Doomsday.
Wait, can I make more stuff?
New creation.
Oh, I can.
I have an idea.
Wait, videos.
What the fuck is videos?
Your images for it that can be gifted to me's me's would
love to watch oh
okay I got an idea for this but I'll do that later because
I'm lazy alright we'll finally do it guys
I'm just gonna use a template
oh shit
whoops you know that works
that works that works and And then...
There we go.
Alright, and then we can figure this out here.
Let's move it out here.
We'll make Dad...
Oh my god.
Okay.
And then...
We'll start erasing stuff.
Here we go.
you see it just works we're smarter not harder guys as i say
oh shit okay i don't know i need to look at this all right
nice i can't see it because i'm covering myself up all right
and now we do what weenerdog dad or dad that's on my head
dad what would be easier, actually.
I can...
Oh, the longer snow.
You're right.
Actual dog.
That is true.
I might actually just do the actual dog.
It is easier.
Weiner dog.
You're right.
I can draw less.
I can draw less stuff
I I like that
okay and then the ears are also
oh wait
it should be brown actually
how do I lock transparency oh there you go oh that doesn't
work wait a minute that doesn't work
And then...
Yay for templates!
Makes my job so easy!
I didn't think I could draw a dog, honestly, on the pad.
It might be too hard for me.
Alright, let's put that.
And...
Let me copy your homework and change it a little bit.
You know?
You'll never know.
It's my new original drawing.
How would they know?
That's right.
I drew all of this by hand.
By scratch.
How would they know?
know.
Oh, wait, I should...
It doesn't feel very accurate to that, so let me... I need
to adjust it a little bit.
Oh.
Okay, now!
That looks like him.
There we go.
It's like, it's missing one more thing.
I think that's perfect.
He does have, like, a little
Nah.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
I mean, it should be like...
Okay, wait.
A little bit like this.
There you go.
That should be everything.
It could be longer.
Which I have an idea.
Whoops.
There we go.
That's long enough now.
Now he's long enough.
We can rebuild him.
There!
Now that's perfect.
That's my dad.
It's beautiful.
There he is.
I gotta fix his mouth a little bit.
Hey, I think it's, why is this back weird?
Don't worry about it.
D-A-D.
D-A-D, okay.
Dad.
All right, well, you put it all in capital.
Apparently, it's just D-A-D.
All right, dad.
Trit.
fierce or charming depending on fierce or fierce it depends
on who he's talking to or unless you're a pretty lady or not
that i've got that thomas has never ever seen such before
face even shaped like take ancient asia thank you in the
super chat thank you thank you that's hopping
do hopping no sound
woof woof
I'm a dog
okay it can't be that
what's in a dog what's in a dog what's in a dog what's in a
dog what's in a dog
I don't want the extra squeaky do that and then I realize we
need I'm a real dog just in case people doubt I want people
to know that that's a real dog Oh, that's why I could put
calm I can try To have a little pause Woof, I'm a real dog
Yeah, I'm a real dog Yeah, it does work With in a real dog
With in a real dog Alright, 10 or 8 Wait, or six?
I'm a real dog.
Wait, or six?
Wait, I need to clarify just in case people are like, are
you-is that a real dog?
And you're like, oh, that is a real dog.
Alright, six?
Or ten or eight.
Six?
I'm a real dog.
All right, trust me, he's a real dog.
I'm doing six.
There's dad.
Yay, we have dad.
I just buy him.
He is a real dog.
Thank you very much.
All right, I give that to...
Gotta give that to Doki.
Doki Prime.
Something you need?
Got you a present, Doki.
where's dad look at him he's so long it's probably a dog
oh my god when will she use it though oh oh is she bringing
it home wait I think she might bring it home oh oh oh
look at him go oh my god Doki's taking dad he's trying to
walk right
There she is!
There he goes!
I'm a real dog.
You're a smart one, Dad.
I'm a real dog!
You're a smart one!
He's getting his luckies!
Look how happy they are!
look at them go oh taking him to the grass you got pee and
poop oh my god let's get a little pet
it's so cute
all right he pooped guys he pooped she didn't pick up the
poop but that's so that's that's not okay but that's okay
Patch is gonna die.
A patch of grass is gonna die now.
Who ain't a good poopy?
Or is she gonna take him now?
Thank you.
I drew this from scratch.
It's very hard.
I'm gonna follow them.
I'm gonna follow their walk.
I'm memorizing the routes.
I did this.
Why doesn't he bark?
Oh, oh, oh, she picked him up.
Where is the dragon?
Oh, you guys were hanging out.
After remembering urgent task.
What's the task, dragon?
I would hope so.
Oh, you have something to say?
What is it?
That's a great idea.
Yes!
What would...
What would Doki like to turn back the triangle?
Yes!
Okay, but check this out.
Check what out
Wow dragon, I didn't know you you you you freak like that
dragon I didn't know that Dragon that's damn, I didn't know
you're freaking like that dragon good good friends now oh
the one time i don't think this was how it was gonna happen
all right thank you for the super chat all right thank you
thank you wait
My sexy oh shit.
Thank god I'm a long dude.
Hey guys, thank you.
Let's see for chat.
Thank you.
Makes sense.
Joe Dunes and I have the same taste and hobbies.
So no wonder we hit it off.
Yay!
I'm so glad your visa got approved to Tokyo Island, guys.
I'm so happy.
Oh, here.
You need some muscle building.
Got some muscle building, too, to impress her.
We should have read the NDA in terms of service.
Oh, my God.
You guys became friends so fast.
What natural chemistry, YouTube.
have i'm
filing a restraining order good buddy thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you is it unlocked now oh i need
two okay wait island builder oh i got wooden boards what the
am i gonna do with wooden boards is there anything new
there's ballet oh karate what a little works.
Cleaning styles.
I'll get more pallet stuff.
Exteriors.
I'm too lazy to draw stuff for houses.
Ooh, interiors, maybe?
Nah.
I'll save up.
I'll use it for later.
Oh my god, you guys are working out together, guys.
Okay.
Oh my god, you two are working out together right now.
You guys are bonding.
It's great to see you guys all bonding together.
Kind of discussing things they've had on their minds.
Oh, what did Doki notice?
What does Doki want to do?
Oh, she just wants to look at the lamp post.
It wants some company.
You know what?
I'll let you talk to the dragon.
All right, enough talking.
Oh.
Oh, they haven't met yet.
Oh,
now they know each other.
This beloved lasagna collection.
Nice.
You seem like mine did.
No problem.
New friend.
Wait, where did he go?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You want to do something, Doki?
Wait, actually.
Where's dragons?
Dragon.
Dragoon.
Oh, wait, what's going on in Faze Clan's house?
Oh, hey, Doki.
That's the game one, right?
Yeah.
No.
I won't play a game right now.
Dragoon.
He Dragoon.
Why don't you head to the restaurant, Dragoon?
Oh, yes.
You don't know who should be there at the restaurant with
you?
Leave us alone.
Believe me?
Oh, my sexy OG.
Oh, look at that.
It's because we got to turn into real Fortnite V.
Folks.
So natural.
I can't believe the dragon naturally went into the
restaurant with sexy dokey oh my god what are the odds hello
oh she wants to be able to do aerobics with it maybe grew
we'll do aerobics with dokey field oh hey dokey good evening
grew from despicable me movie oh he's pretending to be naive
about swans nice nice Now they want me friends.
Yay!
I thought they were going to do aerobics, but I guess not.
What's going on over here?
Featuring favorite types of orange juice.
Everyone's having such a great time on my island.
I'm going to use the bathroom real quick, guys.
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
And!
Forward!
Nexi, Anya, and Medi, bye.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is everyone on my island having a good time?
Oh, hey, Doki.
I'm going to bring someone over.
I'm bringing...
Who do I bring over?
Who's free?
Oh, he's listening to reggaeton.
Look at Doki, go.
Where's Doki feel?
Oh, he's hanging out with Gru.
I shouldn't bother him.
All right, tomato.
You go dance for Doki.
Doki.
Go help Doki.
That other Doki is so clumsy.
Gravity wins again?
She fell and can't get up again.
She's so clumsy.
Uh, what does that mean?
I owe you one?
Silly Doki.
I feel like to make more me said, lock more stuff.
Is that it?
guys come on guys do something on my island do something
oh she's blowing bubbles that's so cute
there you go wow she's so good at blowing bubbles how many
me's do i i remember like someone made like a blank canvas
me and they banish it in an island like over here some shit
where it's just all a blank mees and stuff, because they
just want to keep unlocking things.
That was fucking funny.
What if I just make this island just all dragons?
Well, you guys just stay here.
I just keep making mees, and it's just all dragons stuck in
this one island.
Like the me clone five.
You're not allowed.
Protect, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Waiting for your visas to get approved.
It's walled off of paradise.
Oh?
Yeah, talk to him.
Go for it.
Bad name.
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Doki.
Hello, bear.
Unknown as Groove from the Despicable Me movie.
Yay!
Now they know each other.
Her best story is always like all of the horror games that
she played.
For you, Doki.
I'm proud of you for getting out of your comfort zone to
talk to Groove from the Despicable Me movie.
I'm so proud of you.
Oh, he's working out right now.
I didn't buy something new.
Let's see.
Who does her?
Who should wear this new outfit I have?
Oh.
Oh, Doki wants to play a game.
Oh, Doki.
Won't you try stealing the moon with me?
That's all she wants, guys.
Wait, is she having a conversation about gooning with
Groove?
Alright, I want to...
Alright, Kroki, I got you a new outfit.
No, that's too much.
I'll give you this.
You're so hardcore, Doki.
Wait, where's your hat?
Where's your hat?
She took, oh my god, bald, bald, bald.
What the hell?
Oh, she leveled up.
Alright, we'll add this.
Catchphrase.
It's me, Doki.
Hello, I am Doki.
What do you mean, kak?
There you go.
apparently yeah oh you're right should be like all caps
okay and then how do you do it it was like
got the view
oh wait that works
this is make it longer okay it us oh my god we broke the
system it's like tts we're like it's like doing tts guys we
make it like sing songs and stuff in w w w w w w five five
five five i got the strats the tts it died okay wait maybe
not the strats
I got the strap.
We just add more Oz.
Okay.
Oh, someone said extend the dash.
Does extending the dash actually do anything?
No, extending dash doesn't do anything.
Okay.
We just keep adding Oz.
We can keep going.
We can make it longer.
We make it longer.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, exclamation point?
Wait, does exclamation point change anything?
No, it doesn't.
Wait, and then we do this.
Chichichich.
Chich.
Wait, what are we?
I know, like...
It's
like, you're sorry.
Thank you for the secret chat.
Thank you.
Fuck.
That's perfect.
That's perfect, Doki.
Cah!
Here you go.
This is your new catchphrase.
I've always wanted to say that.
Me too, Doki.
Me too.
Oh my god, he's working out.
Oh my god.
Go, dragon.
Go.
He's getting swirled right now.
Oh yeah, she needs her hat.
back you're right she's still bald it's really good that
we're trying not to commit tax fraud I'm really proud of you
guys okay we gotta fix your outfit gotta wear your hat again
now wear your hat there we go bald oh hey Kevin what are you
thinking about um yeah good evening yes kevin i think a
change of pace might be nice i want to move into a new home
what do you think you should yeah i think so too should i
bring along anyone i've been living with don't
bring them don't
bring drama don't bring them
Let's build Kevin a new house.
The plot.
Oh my god.
It's one house again.
Oh wait, I can't even move it.
Oh my god.
And then live next to the dragon.
Yes.
As of today, this is my new home.
Oh my god.
gonna come back and gonna be like where did kevin go my
house oh
paper that's all he kept from the old house that's all he
kept him and his toilet paper kevin had all the furniture he
looked so depressed he had all the furniture it's all right
it's okay grew i don't know Who can entertain you?
Doki is staring.
Alright, I guess that will work too.
I guess that will work.
Hi, Doki.
Today is my birthday as a gift.
Can you stop making dragons interact with the Doki in the
swimsuit?
Thanks.
Thank you, Melissa.
For chat, Smug.
Thank you, thank you.
Look.
Look, Smug.
Sometimes growing up is learning that not everything will go
your way.
Sometimes you just can't have everything smug, but happy
birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear smug.
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Oh?
Offer an open invitation saying I'm wide open.
Let's actually get together.
there soon.
Oh, and she wants to hang out.
Oh, my Doki's so happy.
I need a few more Mies to build a Ferris wheel.
Oh, how many more Mies do I need?
That's right, Doki.
Go dance.
Yay!
God, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
I know.
Doki's just so funny.
They're great friends now.
Oh my god, I know.
She's just such a natural.
Oh, Doki and Doki sure get a lot.
Guys, how many more memes do...
Oh, you've been doing great job.
Here's a little song to help make this place even more fun.
You can now open a marketplace!
Yay!
Okay, I want a marketplace.
Yes, please.
We'll build it next to Gru.
We're his...
Oh, wait, actually, I don't think I can fit it.
Why?
Bruce House is too wide.
Build it here.
Wait, is that where?
Oh, wait.
Oh, whoops.
It's on backwards.
I can build it here.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening.
But how many news do I need to open the Ferris wheel, guys?
You want a good place to market?
Well, welcome the news to the marketplace.
opening a pond not related to other islands the marketplace
sells food clothing and what's called a mystery bag oh i
love mystery bag that could be filled with anything maybe
even something you don't like such is the mystery the
morning market runs from 5 a.m to 11 30 a.m the afternoon I
can't believe we have Facebook Marketplace.
Oh my god, it's a Facebook Marketplace, guys.
I have a free refrigerator.
You just gotta come over and pick it up.
I live 30 miles from your place.
Thanks for watching.
Also, make sure to not bring anyone.
Come by yourself.
Not suspicious at all.
day oh i think yellow was like she wanted to tell me
something
oh she's daydreaming she's daydreaming about her potential
new date her potential girlfriend oh yeah and also my house
is in the middle of the woods with no cell reception i'll
give you the coordinates i want to be sweetheart Let's go
for it.
Just do it, Doki.
Stop being a pussy.
I would like to, yes, please.
I would like to get a mystery bag.
Item one.
Udon!
Oh, actually, now I'm craving for Udon.
Two.
A polka dock set.
Item three, the flip-flops.
Wait, I want to buy another one.
Wait, what?
Wait, he closed.
Wait, this is a scam.
Okay.
Can I just close?
I get one a day?
Oh my god, that's how they get you.
That's how they fucking get you.
I guess I'll never know when...
Oh my god, he's still working out.
The dragon is still working out.
So now you can talk to Doki here.
She's still trying to get swole for a sweetheart, for a sexy
Oshi.
Alright, I'm chilling, hanging out.
Alright, I guess we have to make another me for progression.
I don't know what to make now.
I mean, everyone I wanted to make.
Alright, I mean, look at the docopedia.
I mean, I guess...
We have dokeybug.
I could make dokeybug.
It's gonna be a lot harder Oh my god, you're so right
You're so right Maybe I shouldn't make Maybe I shouldn't
make it
Alright Let's see Give me a sec I just gotta pull this up
I'll make an exact copy I think I can do it I think I can
make an exact copy.
All right.
I'm pretty sure she used this face too.
Is that it?
Oh my gosh, she drew custom outfits.
She's more dedicated to this than me.
She's a lot better at this than I am.
I think she's definitely less lazy.
I don't know if I need a bangs.
Is she dry?
No.
It was like...
No, it is.
I don't know if she drew this.
No, there's shading.
Does she shade that?
No.
Oh my god.
Wait, I think she did.
I didn't.
She did it.
But unless it's this.
It's like a fine.
Oh my gosh.
She might have actually drew her hair.
All right.
We'll not make an exact copy.
What do you want?
Never mind.
It might not be an exact copy, guys.
No.
It's like.
Yeah, it'll be like a bit Timu-ish.
Oh, wait.
No, it's this.
Okay.
It is that.
Longer.
This?
Is it longer?
Is there a longer one?
Oh, yeah.
Is this for real?
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's just exactly like that.
And I think she had...
I'm pretty sure she had this.
Alright.
Alright, this or...
No.
It's definitely this.
It's a little dot.
And then the eyes is...
What the fuck is your eyes?
It's like the circular.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, that fucking huge as hell.
Oh, wait.
Does she not have a nose?
Oh, my gosh.
She got rid of her nose.
The surgery was a success.
It's like a extra three.
And then...
Okay, let's fix her eyes.
Just let...
It's basically the same one.
I literally am recreating her exact...
The exact me that she's using.
No, I'm not drawing her...
I'm not redrawing her clothes.
She's getting... She's getting Walmart.
The shit I find at Walmart.
okay oh my god she actually drew the horns though okay wait
a minute i need to see if i actually have like if i have it
in me to fucking draw that those horns
okay it's like yeah it's this one
he's this or wait is she did her cheek this sign too?
Oh my gosh, she did.
Wait.
Okay.
I'll also commit to it.
Alright, I'm adding the face paint.
Alright, we'll see how this goes.
She actually drew in the blush as well.
Okay, but I I need to use...
Wait, what?
Okay.
And then...
Uh...
Oh, no, not that.
Wait, I want to draw...
Oh, it's this.
Wait, no.
It's this.
Paint on top.
There we go.
And then she had like a little...
Oh, my God.
I'm practically recreating her.
Is that it?
Yeah, I think that's it.
And then the horns.
Okay, it's the horns time.
The horns is where...
The horns is where it might get weird.
It might feel it off.
This is where things might not go so well.
Oh.
Good enough.
There will not be a second attempt.
There will not be...
a second attempt at this I'll take that I'll take those
this first try or nothing
I can't believe she had a shading freaking wild
there we go good enough good good enough it's almost it
almost looks the same it's
like here
There we go.
Literally almost looks the same.
Here, this is my reference.
She actually drew an entire outfit for herself.
I was like, I don't know how...
I'm sorry.
That's too much effort for me.
She drew herself her own outfit.
She's stronger than me.
It's almost the same.
I almost recreated perfectly.
It's just the horns.
She's committed to the bit.
Practically looks like the same one.
I think if I get a smaller head, maybe.
But I think that is the smallest head.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Is that...
Yeah, this is the smallest head.
I think the only thing the only thing that's oh wait maybe
oh the eyebrows I got fixed the eyebrows maybe I think so I
think the eyebrows just needs to fix a little like here
there we go yeah there we go practically the same okay yeah
no you're not you're not that tall
I was like oh my god why how did you get chibi's me in here
she will also be dokey dokey my name is dokey
email you'll never find love
That's messed up!
Alright, let's see, okay.
I was trying to find her birthday.
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 7th.
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
It's my name is Doki.
Alright, yeah, that one.
Yes.
Kid of Doki.
I'm not calling the kettle black.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, she's pretty quick.
She has a lot of energy.
She's not chill nor serious.
And she's very quirky.
She'll be six forever.
Forever six.
Well, she's not dating anybody, but I'll just put that here
just in case.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
I actually put 29th.
It should be 30th.
A certain higher guy trusts their own instance and easily
commends the respect of others.
Alright, Doki.
Welcome to Doki Island.
It's just a long line of houses.
I'm making the suburbs.
Alright,
nice.
Alright, we're gonna change your birthday.
We're gonna make you forget what your old birthday was.
Edit me.
Sorry, your mom held you in for one more day.
Alright, nice.
Oh, since you are a dokey, gotta feed you.
Every dokey must have a bite of 67.
See it?
All dokeys love it.
Oh, new news!
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
news.
We've just received some breaking news.
Now that the island is home to 10 residents, we've received
a report of the island.
This represents the overall state of the island.
At this time, not related to other islands as five has been
established as an enthusiast.
We have 10 residents now in Doki Island.
Thanks for watching.
Let's go.
Enter up to date.
Island vibes.
Of course, that's based on the means who live here now.
So the island vibe, which could change as you add new
residents.
You can check your island info at any time to bring up the
menu.
The vibe is listed under additional details.
That's not all you'll find under island info.
You'll see all the island lingo.
Okay.
There's so much stuff about Doki Island there.
It's definitely worth a look sometimes.
Alright.
Alright, Doki.
It's time to meet your dad.
Well, everybody isn't hanging out here.
Where's your dad?
Alright.
Time to meet your dad.
I'm Doki.
Hey, Doki.
Yay!
You're not acquaintances with your dad!
Isn't that great?
Oh yeah, it is scary.
Streaming is scary.
Seems like mining.
Yay!
Oh?
Oh, you're blowing bubbles, Doki.
You know what else you can be doing right now?
What?
I wonder what.
Hey, Doki.
Hey, Drakus.
Yippee.
No!
You always want to play a game.
What kind of game you want to play, Gru?
Hmm.
Do you want to play?
Yeah, let's do it.
Here's your first mystery double shadow.
What are these?
Okay, Amagas pregnant?
I know one is Amagas.
Is that John Orange?
Okay, pregnant Amagas?
Next up, your second mystery double shadow.
what the fuck is that okay it's a muffin maybe a giant
spinach oh it's a bowl of spinach okay i'm gonna say there's
no way that's a butterfly pregnant muffin what the fuck okay
i think it's just two plates of food.
Risota and ratatouille.
Yeah, I was going to say, I feel like for an insect
collection, it's usually in a box.
I'm so good with the shadow quizzes.
I think I'm like, I think I'm like undefeated in it.
Congratulations.
You won.
No losses.
Always the big one.
Oh, oh my god, I could have gotten
it!
There was a fucking dog in there.
What are they blushing?
What are they talking about?
Heroic Tales?
That's the meaning of the lasagna club?
Crokey is jamming out.
I could have had a PNG dog, guys.
Alright, Kevin.
How about you talk with...
talk to dokey dokefield have you met dokefield yet oh good
evening kevin from the minions movie
do you feel like talking about a fortnight vbucks oh my god
i love fortnight vbucks sure so fun fact about me when i
take pictures of a fortnight vbucks they always come out
perfect no way me too it's been a childhood surrounded by
photos of a fortnight vbox it's like being fortnight rich
this can't be real that's the dream of mine too oh my god i
mean it feels like it's like fate yeah right they're flexing
right now how much fortnight vbox they have they're making
nfts yeah they're good friends Looks like our childhood
dreams of being Fortnite V-Bucks photographers have brought
us together.
Yeah, so they can make me YouTube videos about it.
I want some.
I have a thousand dollars.
I just don't know what to spend.
Does he have goods?
I give him stuff already?
No.
I get some Maracas.
I was like, yeah, he's like, for me?
That's the Maracas.
Thank you.
Alright, and they became good friends.
Could make the island pretty with benches.
Is that what the fuck am I gonna do with benches?
Alright.
Oh no, she's falling.
Can't get up.
Gravity wins again.
I have a perfect person to help you out.
Stop.
I'm gonna be okay too.
Right.
Oh no.
Rexy Doki fell down.
I wonder who can help her.
Oh, they're great friends now.
Yay, I'm level 14.
Oh, I sure knew I meant it to you, too.
My outdoor...
Oh, is that outdoor shower?
A butterfly would be nice.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let them shower outside.
They're the guy that replaced all the pillows with tic-tac's
unrelated, Craig.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
All right, let's buy that.
Oh?
Oh, they both have something to tell me.
I don't remember if yellow...
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Doki was with dad.
Got it, Sam.
i want to chat sure i know this is a big ass because you
stop raining for like 15 minutes
nostalgic for my childhood huh
what do you mean nostalgic
Oh, I was like Neo pets, I guess, yeah.
So nostalgic.
Oh, yeah.
I feel like I'm really getting to know you now.
Sure, it does take you back, doesn't it, Doki?
Yay!
It really does take me back, Doki.
Those were the good old days.
What do you mean?
So nostalgic.
Oh, everybody wants to be friends with Doki.
What should we talk about?
Lasagna.
Okay, let's see.
What can we talk about?
What would Doki want to talk about?
Let's see.
I know.
Yeah.
What does Doki feel think about war?
Don't you remember when Garfield ate a house?
I feel like she would relate.
Yeah.
okay but check this out visualize for who do you want to
join you i mean it's not just because you're asking but i
could hear damn right she could eat a house oh it's just
remember where he was at john but john i'm so hungry i'm
sorry john Yay!
Oh!
No!
Sorry, Toki.
Toki 4 is alone.
Not alone.
Follow me, Dad.
You think, guys, he's a real dog, guys.
Whoop!
I'm a real dog.
I hate it.
He's a real dog!
It's very convincing.
I'm starting to believe he's a real dog, guys.
I'm really starting to believe it.
And that punk bubble shows up.
I'm done subbing.
Thank you, Mr. Muflavi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, sir.
Thank you, Super chat.
Thank you.
I'll be stepjack when I'm done.
He's the realest dog on this island.
You're so...
Oh my god, Groo is thinking about Kevin!
Oh!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Bro, Groo, it took Groo only two hours to confess his
feelings.
still it's still doing practice runs oh my god it's
happening it's happening
an island spot you should do it at the restaurant of a
special dish with a catchphrase arrogantly as Gru would
desperately okay wait with a catchphrase I don't even know
what to say
catphrase what should Gru say to him though
would you steal the moon with me you like jazz
I wish I could gift them the moon oh man if I knew he was
going to confess today have drawn the moon for him to give
as a gift i do want to see what desperately would look like
though i'm gonna do desperately should i change what i'm
wearing no no no no you look great all right it's time to
suck myself up and say how i really feel
his heart's beating so fast oh
my god there he is please oh he's so desperate he wants us
to be the kind of couple that splits a short stack of
pancakes he's got an audience too oh my god it's so pathetic
come on kevin what are you gonna say kevin hold it right
there Minions movie.
What?
Toki?
I can test my feelings first.
When?
It means I love Kevin from the Minions movie the most.
Kevin from the Minions movie.
Which of us do you choose?
Oh my god.
Toki, I love to go out with you.
Oh my god, it's just Toki.
I actually have considered Kevin for the minutes.
Oh wait, didn't we just...
She just...
She just did it for the love of the game.
No way!
I have to confess my feelings too.
So...
Richard!
She didn't even do it because she...
Let's do it.
I love that idea.
We're so close.
You can't wait to hear the sound.
She didn't say that she's at home.
Oh, Gregory and Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my gosh, she did it for the love of the game.
She didn't even fucking care.
She was just like, oh, shit, someone's confessing.
I want to join in and just did it to her and him.
I love that idea.
Doki and Kevin.
Mr. Steel, your girl.
all right well now that they're dating okay
wait I don't even know
babe and then it got the childhood friend experience broken
pod thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
it's just kevin he's just yeah and now that they're together
now that they're together it's just name is just kevin now
yeah it's just kevin because they're together now so it's
just kevin that's when you know they're close that's when
you know they're dating oh no crew
Things, uh, they didn't go so well.
Oh, now they're just friends.
Oh, it's sad this went up.
Oh, he's all he can do.
Oh, he could...
When it was my options, I'll have what?
I have something for you, Groo.
Um...
Oh, what can we do?
We got, I, here, have...
Oh, it's so sad.
The music is so sad.
I have some...
Yeah, I'll give him tissues.
Here.
You can cry with this.
Use this to cry with.
You'll need it.
Oh!
Don't worry, I'll give you a little head pat.
Oh, look, the little sadness went away.
Okay, maybe food?
Oh, no, he's...
Maybe food will help.
God, I made him sadder with tissues.
Here, you want udon?
God, I want udon right now.
Soon.
Does food make you happy?
Okay, food makes you happy.
in the sea, Groo.
Don't worry, I'll have something else for you.
I'll give you more food.
You like the nacho?
Okay, how about salami?
Do you like salami?
He's gonna eat his problems away, chat.
Okay, he likes it.
He likes it.
Alright.
I could give him a vacation.
Oh, interior.
I already renovated his room.
Doesn't need more renovation.
Oh, it's so sad.
Oh, where he's gonna go?
Yoki, I'm not gonna play a game with you.
Go cheer up.
Go cheer him up.
Oh, nope.
No one wants to talk it.
You're crying like a little girl.
Drake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Chibi.
Good evening.
What are you thinking about?
My look is lacking a certain something.
Can you get me a top that matches my current outfit?
Yeah, of course I can.
I knew this would come in handy.
I'm going to wait, why don't you like it?
What do you mean?
Oh, no.
Alright, how about this?
How about this, Doki?
You can hang out with
Kevin from the movies
She's like Oh he's shouting out See I'm gonna join you How
is it so fast I'll never give...
Oh?
Oh, Doki's dreaming.
Doki's laying with Dad still.
Oof, I'm a real dog.
How can I catch myself a sweetheart?
You can just tell someone you like them.
I hope you find yourself a real catch.
Oh, that all looks so good.
Yum,
yum, yum, yum, yum.
Eat it.
This would be dark dookie field stream.
Not tomato, dookie.
I couldn't live in a room with a bus.
In a data bus room, it's soon as it arrives.
Oh, yeah, food for thought.
That's a good one.
Food for thought.
Double if it does.
I saw Doki on the cover of a fashion magazine.
Really?
You should get an autographed copy.
She's always doing such interesting things.
I am!
You should all aspire to be so fashionable.
Oh my god, I am!
Oh, I got a menu.
I manifested a restaurant menu.
God, I'm so hungry.
Sweetheart.
Alright, let's...
Alright, let's bring him over.
It's a third.
New sweethearts.
Oh?
Oh, she's beaming a surprise!
Ah, look at that.
You caught my heart some time ago.
Oh!
I knew there was some... I knew...
I knew there was something up when kevin wanted to move out
with group oh my god they're in love i knew something was
happening is she okay
oh it wasn't my go for it talk to you nice to meet you i'm
sophie hey sophie
All right, they're getting familiar now.
What's happening?
Um, Gru's not handling...
Gru's not handling it very well.
It's because you didn't steal the moon, Gru.
If you stole that moon, you two would have been still
together.
Oh my god.
I hope it was just the fruit, right?
The fruit.
He's like, Maraca's time.
And then they are having a great time right now.
Chasing each other.
Look at them go.
Oh, Amagas.
Is he still depressed?
Oh, wait, Sprague.
Maybe we can cheer him up.
Cheer him up.
Oh my god, you're still working out.
You're still working out.
Dragon, cheer him up.
Okay, never mind.
I guess not.
I guess we let him be depressed.
Who cares about him?
Absolute gym, bro.
Go, go, go fix him.
Stop shouting into the sea.
The cry never stops.
I mean, you're not gonna talk to him.
You know what I'm gonna be doing.
Dekun says making funs about Fortnite V-bucks.
We're done!
Oh, I got to look at you to go.
You need to go.
You're having a great time together, hanging out.
Oh my God, you made her laugh!
I like your vibe, Dragoons.
She likes your vibe!
Best friends.
No problem, Dragoon.
I knew you guys would.
look you also had kevin as an option but kevin's not single
anymore what can i do guys he's just not single anymore if i
could i would have given you another option but he just He's
a taken man now, guys.
Let's put the public outdoor shower here.
You know what?
It's time to take a shower, Cheeby.
You're uh-oh, stinky.
There you go.
What happens if, like, Kevin tries to go up to the groove?
Can you anything?
Oh, he's...
What is he doing?
Oh, I have an idea.
Where's...
What the fuck is Doka feel doing?
He's emoting on it.
I'm in a contest of poses.
Right next to Gru?
poke emoting on him Damn That's fucked can't believe he
would do such a thing They have a guitar right I just want
some time alone right now Oh my god, he doesn't even want to
talk to me anymore Oh my god, he's so depressed.
Oh hey, they're hanging out.
Oh my god, they're ordering food together.
Look at that.
What a natural meaning between these two.
Is that crazy?
Oh, Doki needs help.
Who should help Doki?
Is anybody free to help Doki?
All right, Doki.
Help Doki.
Are you all right?
There's the source of the problem.
You might need to use Oh, you interact with sad people in
their house?
Oh, okay.
I got an idea.
All right, girl, we're taking you back to...
All right, girl.
Enough touching grass.
We're going home.
Don't worry, girl.
I'll save you.
I have something.
I think I have a guitar.
So I don't have a guitar.
Here, how will you eat your problems away with a menu?
Or to takeout.
It's on me.
Oh, there we go.
See?
Stress eating.
Yay!
It always works.
Oh, he wants to go out now.
You know what?
Jokefiel might be able to...
Oh.
I give up.
Look, look, Jokefiel's...
Oh, okay.
He doesn't want to...
He doesn't want free music, I guess.
Yeah, food solves everything, guys.
It really does.
Don't give up.
Drew, you'll find love someday.
Kevin.
Bro, don't worry.
One day you'll find love.
There's so...
Oh my god, I thought that...
That was...
I thought that was the dragon.
There's just so many yellows.
Oh, send him on a trip?
Oh, you're right.
I'll send him to Australia again.
Do I need to pay for...
Alright, bro.
Go to Australia.
Maybe I'll have another friend to go with.
Oh.
Hello, Shad.
Yeah.
Are you really giving this to me?
Thank you.
A change.
I think he has, like, no other friends, guys.
I think that's why I couldn't find anyone to cheer him up.
I think his only friend was Kevin.
Oh my god, he's going alone.
That is so sad.
Oh my god.
I forgot to get through any other friends.
He's trying to rewrite the memories that he has.
trying to reminisce about the good old days with him and
Kevin trying to relive those days when he was happy I don't
think I want to save these photos it's too sad the places
they used to visit together I didn't think Kevin was gonna
reject him
There was no one else!
Oh, another co-op flesh.
Nice.
Wait, he did!
He did have other friends!
I'm feeling better now!
My god, Sexy Doki is like knows everybody on this island.
This just like Despicable Me Too where Gru goes to
Australia.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
you there's a secret that's not fair come on let me in on it
all right crew it's time to go out there oh oh got your nose
all right crew oh new news oh he feels better now he's back
at work
Yay!
We're going to go to Hawaii!
A Hawaii tour is now available via travel tickets Oh my god,
now he's back at work.
He feels better now.
And one resident is floating in the same.
I hope my roommate is gifted a trip soon.
I could really use the alone time.
Wait, there's only one, there's only one house that has
roommates.
So someone can leave immediately.
Stop by the wishing fountain to learn more.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Gru from Despicable Me movie.
Interrupted date.
Alright, Gru.
We're gonna go out there.
You're gonna meet new Doki.
girl okay not her she's already we already have plans for
her oh my god we'll create a new love triangle what yeah
what am i up to okay watch this i'll force more interactions
oh never mind to say something.
Hey, Doki.
Good evening.
I feel like I could use this dollop.
Oh, yammy yammy we'll give you something.
Yeah, you can wear a backpack.
Yay!
What does she have in that backpack, I wonder?
Create a new love triangle.
More drama, drama, Doki.
island oh my god look at him they're sharing chill memories
of lasagna oh my god don't keep track on your earth just oh
he's working out that's all you have in your brain right now
25 look at you go 27 let's
see where is where's Doki go Oh, hang out with your dad
more.
Oh my god, Doki's hanging out with dad.
Woof.
Doki, good evening.
Alright, nice.
I'm glad you two are hanging out more.
The grind ever stops.
You're on an island filled with Doki's and all you're doing
is working out.
Are you still working?
Okay, you're done working out.
Okay, that's good.
Kevin,
I don't want to play.
Um, I've got some time on my hands.
Do you want to play me Shadow Quiz with me?
No.
Alright, Kevin.
Wait, I haven't met.
Oh, you... Have you met?
Oh, yeah, you guys have.
Oh?
Self-published short stories.
Showering next to Yoki and Grill.
I'm surprised Yoki hasn't confessed to Yoki yet.
She has been like crushing for a couple of days now.
It's my little...
It's a wet tomato.
Oh my gosh.
Do something.
Where's my drama?
Ever since that rush.
The love triangle rush.
I need more.
interact them maybe make them interact a little all right
dokey it's time to interact with them
oh you guys haven't talked yet hey nice to meet you i'm
dokey hey dokey i'm dokey
all right well they seem like mine and they're always like
mine it oh look at grew he's here to stress you forget about
all the sadness in life all right girl it's time to get over
it all right strangers acquaintances all right it might be
too much don't worry don't worry i got you let's go back to
your the place where it all started let's bring the trauma
something on your we're going to do exposure therapy why
bring him back so you can hang out and then we're
at all began
oh all right showers over hello
it's We should never even met Gru before.
He's never even met him.
He fucking doesn't even know who he is.
He still stole him from him.
I didn't even realize.
That's even...
That might be even more messed up.
Not gonna lie.
He never even met him before.
Oh, why is it pink?
Wait, do you have a crush?
I can't explain it, but Doki is on my mind.
Sounds right.
Oh my God, my O-sheet.
I knew it.
I'm in love with Doki.
I want to show it to the mountaintop.
I'd love to go on a date with Doki.
Yes.
Now it's a Doki triangle.
Oh my god.
It's a dokey triangle.
Which dokey would fall?
Which dokey would go to which dokey?
Oh my god, one more dokey.
We need a dokey square.
Yeah, level 15.
Yeah, yippin.
so now i can go to hawaii oh i got new items little quirks
appetite set what is that big eater little eater meh on
guitar okay i wanted to gift through a guitar so he could
sing his oh my god oh my god they're becoming good friends
guys look at that he's becoming friends with his crush's
boyfriend oh i can't gift it yet until he levels up
all right we're gonna call it here i think more stuff will
unlock if i have more means but i'm not i i don't know which
i don't want to make another me right now they take so much
work I don't really feel like making another me at the
moment.
I thought it was fun.
Another day.
Another drama filled day on Doki Island.
I live, I love it.
I live for these moments.
It feeds me.
It feeds my life.
It, ha ha ha.
A lot of stuff has happened on Doki Island.
I was so hungry.
Now my hunger is satisfied.
As always, everybody, I'm going to go head off now.
So, tomorrow we're going to play Vampire Crawlers.
It is a, it's basically a, what do I say?
It's a spin-off of, well, it's not really a spin-off, but
it's a different type of genre for vampire, it's called
Vampire Hunters.
But it's a different type of genre, different type of game.
But it's based off of the IP.
Vampire survivors.
I was like, what, I know it starts with vampires.
Sorry.
It's from the creators of vampire survivors.
And they made a card roguelike game called Vampire Crawler.
So I'm looking forward to trying that out because I haven't
played a lot of card type games before, but I saw a lot of
reviews and they were all really, really good.
So I'm super excited to check it out.
Oh yeah, I've got to save the game.
I've got to save my island.
Save, please.
I'll stop here.
Yeah, for watching um for watching the adventures at doki
island um i was hungry for drama and i it did not disappoint
anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check
get up and move around and get that blood flowing and if you
stood up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see
you guys next time everybody bye guys bye